Welcome and thank you to
another lecture on immunology.
In this case, we're
going to talk about
mechanisms of autoimmunity
and rheumatological disease.
By now, you should know me.
My name is Dato Slingman.
I'm both Director of
Academic Affairs and
Associate Professor and
also Founding Director
of the Master's in
Biomedical Sciences.
I hope you enjoyed
this lecture.
These are decision
objectives. At the end of this
lecture, students or
learners should be able to
describe the phenomena of
tolerance, immunity, and
pathological implications,
should be able to
compare central and peripheral
tolerance, should be
able to define autoimmunity,
describe the three
stages of an autoimmune
disease, and identify the
mechanisms of pathogenesis
of autoimmune diseases.
So this is where it becomes
kind of a difficult task
for the immune system. it
has to basically fulfill two
different requirements and
almost opposite one of them
you have to have basically
a large variety of different
receptors and that combined
every potential foreign
substance that's out there
so that means billions and
millions of billions of
modifications and shapes and so
forth so that you don't
have a pathogen that we have
absolutely no receptor that
can fit or basically antibodies
that can bind you. At the
same time, this repertoire
of receptors or antibodies,
if you're on a column,
have to be in a way that
covers all these pathogens
but do not attack our
immune system. So that could
be quite the undertaking
to be done by the immune
system to be able to have these
two different contradictory
requirements and maintain
both. Now, let's be
honest, the immune system
has done a fantastic job
evolving to actually do both
of these tasks very well.
One way,
and as you can see here
in this particular figure
right here, is that we
have multiple different
genes that are actually
responsible, for example,
to generate the T cell
receptor. And these different
genes can actually
rearrange themselves in
different ways to generate,
almost theoretically,
10 to the 15 different
T cell receptors.
So almost,
you know, way more than
a billion for sure.
and so this ability
of rearranging genes
can provide our body
with a significant
advantage of generating
so many different
receptors that combine so
many different antigens.
The idea of autoimmunity
originated quite early
with the turn of the 19th
century with Paul Ehrlich,
the scientist and bacteriologist,
who actually coined
the term holo-autotoxus
and what he was trying to
refer to is that the
necessity to avoid actual
immunological reaction against
our own antigens and basically
he is one of the first
person to recognize the
phenomena of autoimmunity
as it occurs in a person's
body and he these are some
of his illustrations on
the right side here shown
one like receptor binding and
of course these are very
preliminary and we're
talking over 120 years ago
but it's interesting that you
know he was fathoming what
that would look like so
let us discuss the phenomena of
thalons and thalons
is a very important
term when it comes
to the immune system
basically thalons is
defined as antigen specific
and responsiveness
the ability to to see
an antigen but choose
not to respond to it
Obviously, this is a
result of a program
developmental process.
It happens early
on in life. We learn
how not to respond to
certain things while
respond to others.
Basically, throughout that,
our adaptive immune response,
both the B cells and
T-cellotoxic cells
tolerate cell antigens or
sometimes called auto
antigens. And at the same time,
they need to also tolerate
foreign substances like
dietary proteins that
eat and the immune system
should not you know basically
attack a hamburger or
attack anything that it
sees and so it has to be
able to do that balance
and recognize this is self
this is just benign
this is not something
that's my cause of an
issue and juggle of that
to in the opposite of
tolerance so when tolerance
is broken we get
autoimmunity so our immunity
by definition is the
breakdown in tolerance and
typically that requires
that we have self-reactive
t-cells so they have to
be able to react to our
own antigens for that to
occur now those exist in
every single one of us
they are the exception
they're not the majority
a lot of more eliminated
early on in the development
but some do linger and
have to be maintained
or suppressed throughout
the life of an individual
to ensure that we don't
have autoimmunity but as
you know sometimes that
is not foolproof
and autoimmunity
does occur in a few thankfully
to explore more tolerance
tolerance can be divided
into two different types
central tolerance and
peripheral tolerance and
the difference is basically
in the location of these
processes. So central
tolerance occurs in
what's referred to as the
primary lymphoid
organs and that is our
bone marrow and the
thymus. So of course
bone marrow is where
our B cells mature and
the thymus is where
our T cells mature.
So a lot of times
people remember
B cells, B for bone marrow,
right?
B for bone marrow and
T for thymus. Although
this is not very
accurate, although it
The bee comes from a
chicken organ called Bursa
of Fabricus. That's where
the bee came from, but it
apparently happened to
line up with Ben Morris.
So it worked.
Central thalamus play a
very important role, as
stated here, but only part
of the story. It's one
of the first things
that happened early in
development in life where
we pretty much wipe off
almost 99% of most of our
cells, our T and B cells.
then afterwards for the
rest of our life we have
to maintain tolerance
through our peripheral organ
to ensure any cells that
slip through here and do
not die but they can
still bind to our antigens
are suppressed and that's
referred to as peripheral
tolerance and that occurs
in our secondary point
organs you know things
like the spleen the tonsils
the adenoids the lymph
lymph nodes, et cetera.
Let's discuss central
tolerance more specifically.
So, of course,
central tolerance
predominantly happens in
the thymus and with the
involvement, of course,
of the bone marrow.
But cells that are basically
V cells and T cells that
start out in the bone marrow
migrate to the thymus.
And in different locations
of the thymus, we'll
talk about that too. and
we discussed this if you
remember last semester in
the histology of the immune
system lecture so I would
encourage you to go back
and review that in light
of understanding this
but just a quick recap
thymocytes that come from the
bone marrow to the thymus
undergo both type of
processes positive selection
and negative selection.
Okay,
so positive selection is
the process of selecting
thymocytes with
receptors that can both
recognize and bind MHC1
receptors. So they have
to be able to bind MHC1
receptors to be able to
recognize cell antigen
from non-cell antigen.
And those will end up
surviving. Now if they don't,
sorry, if they end up
binding too strong to MHC
receptors or to the cell
peptides presented by
MHC, then they are killed
or deleted and that's
called negative selection.
So negatively selecting
for something is ripening
it out while positively
selecting something,
allowing it to move forward.
As we said early on in our
foundation scores, less
than 5% of all our T cells
end up surviving this.
So 95 percent of them are
wiped out through negative
selection and only five
percent move forward and
those exit as what's called
naive mature T cells. They
still have to undergo
training and recognize and
so on and if you recall a
lot of this learning happens
in the thymus both in the
cortex and the medulla.
There's different type
of cells that help them
with that, specifically
thymic endothelial
cells that help these
processes go together.
All the efforts made
by the thymus and the
process of central
tolerance, a good number of
low-ability self-reactive
T cells still escape
to the peripheral and
end up in our body
for the rest of our
lives and so that's a
significant number
nevertheless don't forget that
peripheral tolerance plays
a very important role
here in maintaining
suppression of these cells
and so you really cannot
delete every single cell
the other issue is some
of these cells may be
necessary to defend us
from other pathogens so it
becomes a balancing act
of how many to let go and
then how to maintain the
suppression over them
okay there's also the
the variation or the uh
concentrations of for example
how much of the antigen is
there uh versus uh the strength
of the tcl receptor and
so if there's a lot of
antigen sometimes even a lot
of the tcl receptor will
still find something to
bind to but the antigen we
don't have as much of it then
the likelihood of this
receptor binding the engine
and binding to it is going
to decrease. There's that
concentration gradient that
plays a role in how many
of these cells are going
to bind to their antigen.
Now the medium or high
affinity self-reactive
T cells, those end up
being T regulatory cells.
And T regulatory cells
we've mentioned before,
there is subset of T
helper cells, and we talked
about that being very
important in regulating
immune response and
suppressing immune
response. And we'll discuss
them a lot more here
in this particular
subject or lecture.
As we just talked about,
that autoreactive T cells
are really a normal part of
our cells. There's always
ones in every single one
of us, like all of us may
have T cells that recognize
insulin or even myelin,
and these cells are isolated
from people that have
never experienced type 1
diabetes or multiple sclerosis
but they still have them.
The key thing is whether
we have or not is to maintain
tolerance, peripheral
tolerance, and make sure
they don't become active.
We also have what's called
tolerogenic dendritic
cells. These are not
the same as the typical
dendritic cells that present
antigen, which are the
immunogenic ones. These
are actually designed
specifically to induce
tolerance in T-cells once
presented an antigen. So
this is also another way
by which we can generate
or maintain tolerance.
B-cell tolerance is the same
concept as T-cell tolerance.
The difference is it
happens in the monomero.
So there's some
negative selection
of B-cells that react
to cell antigens. If
they do, they undergo
apoptosis in that.
But there's also another
phenomena called V
-cell receptor editing
and that is actual
modification of the IgD
receptor that can happen
and make sure it doesn't
mine anymore so you can
actually edit that and
make it not as reactive
and it can move forward. As
you can see in the slide here,
if they're self-reactive,
if you do up receptor
editing and works to no
longer react they can
move on survive sometimes
even receptor editing
they still end up reacting
with self and then
those end up getting
killed by apoptosis so
between these two processes
you ensure that b cells
only b cells that
predominantly react to foreign
substances but not to self
-antigen move on and this
is all done with the guidance
of t-cells as expected
because they control the
adaptive immune response.
This is a flow chart that
outlines basically the
process. So we have talons
and of course if talons
ruptures that's what we
define as autoimmunity and
again talons is two types
central and peripheral.
Central because occurs
in primary lymphoid
organs where peripheral
occurs in secondary
organs. This also
happens early on in life.
This occurs in the thymus
and mormarum. Thymus is
where you get T cell tolerance
and in mormar we get B
cell tolerance. Again, it
can happen through deletion
of apoptosis or receptor
editing. We haven't, we
talked about that last time
where there's hyper mutation
or further editing of B
cell receptors to modify
them so they'll no longer
bind to the integer and most
of the t-cells are killed
by a negative selection.
When it comes to peripheral
tolerance it happens
at secondary default organs
and then we'll discuss
next how that happens.
There's multiple mechanisms
that explain how peripheral
tolerance takes place.
There are several mechanisms
at least six that we
know of by which peripheral
tolerance is achieved,
and we'll discuss each of
them in the next slides,
but basically clonal energy,
immunologic ignorance,
cytokine withdrawal,
sequestration, specifically
of like T cells,
idiotype network theory, and
the role of T regulatory cells.
So let's discuss clonal
energy. Clonal energy,
basically, when you have
self-reactive T cells that
do not receive the necessary
co-stimulatory signal,
which is your CD28-B7
interaction after the TCR
MHC class 2 interaction.
In the absence of this,
just trying to move along here,
in the absence of these
stimulation, you
will not be able to
to achieve activation of
the cell, and so what ends
up happening is it becomes
anergic okay so again
typically here if you see
like cells make cytokines
the dendritic cells present
to to the CD4 cell so
there's the dendritic cell
trying to interact and there's
your T cell receptor MHC
class 2 and here's the
CD2087. So sometimes
B7. Without that co
-stimitory signal,
you won't be able to
neither present
antigen and the cell
becomes energy, which
means energy means
basically it's just
not responsive anymore.
So again, if you review
what are all the signals
required, we have to
have that T cell receptor
MHC class 2 interaction.
We have that co-stimitory
signal, which then
results in the secretion
of cytokines, any
disruptions of this process,
and you will not have
stimulation happening. So,
okay.
Now, I apologize for these
next ones. And there's
another phenomenon called
immunologic ignorance, and that's
basically a different
phenomenon where the t-cell
really does not recognize
the antigen at all has no
understanding of it and so
it doesn't react to it that's
a little bit different
from energy because energy
is because of the absence
of a signal here there's
nothing going on it just it's
not part of the repertoire
and a third
and on this slide that
we talk about is cytokine
withdrawals as we said
before if you do have
mhc interaction and
you get the stimulatory
the co-stimulatory
signal but if there's no
cytokines especially io2
which is the major activator
of t-cells or you
know for example now
enough receptors uh the
t-cell will not become
active anyway so these
mechanisms clonal energy
immunologic ignorance
and cytokine withdrawal
can all explain how we
tolerate antigens or
how self-reactive t
-cells still tolerate
antigens in the uh so to
speak peripheral system
The fourth mechanism
we will discuss is
sequestration of potentially
harm for T cells.
So basically what happens
by sequestration can be
different ways. It can be
either physical, such as the
presence of like the
blood-brain barrier in the
brain that prevents actual
T cells from, and a lot of
immune system cells from
actually going into the
brain. If you remember from
your neural lectures, the
blood-brain barrier is
basically a system of tight
junctions that is imposed
on the endothelial cells of
the brain typically imposed
by estrocytes which are
the glial cells one of the
most common glial cells
in the brain so the blood
-brain barrier prevents t
-cells from entering the brain
and so you you physically
prevent these cells from
going there another one
is chemical how you
chemically sequester t-cells
basically by controlling
chemokines selectins and
migration of these t-cells
to different tissues. If you
don't call on them, so to
speak, they won't come.
Next is what's referred
to as the idiotype network
theory. This theory
basically suggests that
antibodies that we make
against self-reactive
antibodies ensures that
we shut those down. So, if
you make an antibody
against an antigen in the
body, then that antibody
now becomes a target
for another antibody.
That's what idiotype means,
one antibody against
another antibody.
And so that's basically
eventually shuts
down those antibodies
and prevent them
from interacting with
the self-antigen.
Now we're going to talk
about our very important
cells. We mentioned them
several times before, T
regulatory cells. If you
remember, T regulatory cells
are medium to high affinity
self-reactive T cells.
We talked about those before.
They're basically a type
of T helper cell, and
the only way to really
fish them out is their
expression of this gene,
FOXP3, and that's how
you're able to identify
them. They made up almost
10% of all CD4 positive
T cells, and they also,
of course, as all T cells,
they express the CD3
receptor. So, that does
not make them unique,
but the FOXP3 does.
Again, what are their
functions? Suppressed
immune system, they squeeze
multiple suppressive
cytokines such as tumor
growth factor beta,
transforming, sorry,
growth factor beta, IL-10,
and they also cause
depletion of IL-2. As we
know, IL-2 is the main
proliferator of T cells and
they can actually kill
CD8 cells, T cytotoxic,
natural killer, B cells
and even dendritic cells.
So they are very powerful
cells that help us
maintain suppression of
the immune system. They
also control how much
immunity we do against like
react on infection, allergens,
tumors, grafts, etc.
So they play a very
important role in making sure
the immune system doesn't
go haywire or continue
to, that positive loop
of just more cytokines,
more inflammation, more
cytokines, more inflammation,
which results eventually
in disaster. So T
-Rex always have a place
in the immune response.
There's a syndrome
which is called IPEX syndrome.
And again, they typically have
questions on this on the boards
that relates to T
regulatory cells.
So again,
autoimmunity can result,
as we talked about,
break intelligence. And this
could be, again, loss of
function. Could be a few
T regulatory cells clones
that have died and we lost
them so that could happen,
you know,
and it could result
in autoimmunity.
Again, this is just exploring
the role and showing
you a figure of T regulatory
cells and how they work,
again, so they can come
and block and affect your
T cell and so results
non-immunity we talked a
little bit about the apex
syndrome that's typically
caused by a mutation in
the fox p3 gene which then
results in absence of t
regulatory cells sometimes
they lose expression and
of course in the absence of
that you'll get autoimmune
diseases as a result um
typically this is how
for example if t-cells
don't work very well you
get a deficiency and that's
been identified in some
conditions like rheumatoid
arthritis so the
block that the t-cell
regulatory cells usually do on
the effector t-cells can
be inhibited like here
resulting in autoimmunity
such as in the case of
IPEX syndrome or in the
case of rheumatoid arthritis
so those both of these
syndromes are directly
related to the function
of T regulatory cells.
And sometimes you may
have resistance of the
effector T cell to T
regulatory functions.
It could happen.
So there again, it's
not hundred percent
foolproof, but they
definitely play a major
role in suppressing
our immune response.
So we just spoke extensively
about different mechanisms
of how peripheral tolerance
is established. Now
knowing that information
actually has a lot of interesting
applications that I'd
like to share with you,
one of them is maintaining
tolerance or even restoring
tolerance is a good approach
to treating autoimmunity,
allergic reactions or
type 1 hypersensitivities,
transplantation so when
you try to transplant let's
say or graft something into
a host one of the things
you want to do is try to
make sure that the person
is tolerating these tissues
so that's so that's one
objective of this and the
other one is kind of the
opposite is you want to for
example in treating tumors
you want the immune system
to not tolerate though
that those tumor cells,
despite tumor cells, our own
body cells. So find a way
to awaken or even overcome
the tolerance that
typically exists or normally
exists in order for the
immune system to kill
that tumor. So two different
approaches, completely
opposite. One of them
is trying to get rid of
tolerance in order to
kill our own cells versus
trying to increase
tolerance for maybe outside
cells or our own or some
allergen that's kind of
useless. So, interesting
ways of looking at that.
These are some review
questions for you to practice.
You should be able to find
the answers for all of
those obviously in the
material we just talked about.
This helps break the
lecture a little bit and
provide you with some
feedback on what you learned.
So, so far we've discussed
tolerance, central,
peripheral and how our immune
system handles that. Now
we're going to move on
to the second part of the
lecture and talk about
autoimmunity and how autoimmunity
happens. So again we've
defined this before,
autoimmunity is when
self-tolerance is
broken. Basically it
refers to as tolerance
rupture and then the
individual or patient
becomes victim of their
own immune system.
And so again that results from
previously
established tolerance.
On the slide right here,
we already discussed that
and talked about how central
peripheral is kind of a
review of all these
mechanisms of again when those
but this does not occur we
end up with autoimmunity.
It's important to note
that autoimmunity is not a
inflammatory so to speak
process inflammation which is
usually a normal part of our
normal immune response. In
this case that's not the
case. So this is not an
inflammatory disease or an
inflammatory process, and it's
not a collateral damage as
such, which could happen
a lot of times with
inflammatory diseases, but this
is not the case here. Okay,
so this is important to note
the difference between
inflammatory-based diseases
or inflammatory damage as
a result of overreaction
of the immune system,
you know, more of
a side effect of fighting
a pathogen rather
than an intentional attack
on the tissue itself
okay so for example
there's there is a like
auto-inflammatory diseases
like tnf associated
periodic syndrome i
would also argue crohn's
disease all sorts of
colitis are all examples
of inflammatory disease
inflammatory bowel
syndrome and they involve
the immune system but
they're not autoimmune
diseases by definition.
So that's an important
distinction to make.
Again, to reiterate,
autoimmunity is an antigen-driven
process. So it's specific,
it's not a spillover or
just side collateral damage.
It's actually specific
to that antigen. There is
a high affinity between the
immune system and the cells
and there's even memory
sometimes. The slabs
shouldn't keep attacking that.
That's in addition to
having an autoreactive
lymphocytes or which can
also produce autoreactive
antibodies again and
this results in the
pathogenesis of disease
basically recognizing
an antigen a self
antigen and destroying it
so one of the key ways to
distinguish other immune
diseases is whether they're
not organ specific or
systemic. So, organ-specific
autoimmune diseases usually
react to a single antigen
and restricted to that single
antigen. Now, that
antigen may be distributed
throughout the body, okay,
but that's still considered
organ-specific. So, for
example, targeting a specific
receptor. Now, that
receptor may be widespread,
but it does not make it
systemic. On the other
hand, when the autoimmune
disease or the body
targets multiple different
antigen, let's say double
stranded DNA and RNA and
nuclear receptors and
so on forth and that
becomes a systemic disease.
So these are examples
for example of you know
specific organ specific
disease like multiple
sclerosis. So a target
here in this case is myelin
sheath only in the central
nervous system. Okay,
so that makes it, you
know, very, very specific.
With the case of insulin
-dependent diabetes
mellitus, the actual
target is beta cells, very
specific beta cells in
the alice of Langerhans.
On the other hand, you
have diseases like systemic
lupus erythromatosis
or just simply lupus
that targets the kidney,
the skin, multiple organs,
and multiple receptors
throughout the body.
So one way to look at this
kind of a really neat figure
that shows you kind of
like how you start out with
on the spectrum of very
specific organ-specific
diseases to very general ones
that are more systemic and
target multiple. So of
course Hashimoto's arthritis,
pernicious anemia,
Addison disease, insulin
-dependent diabetes, myathemia
gravis are all considered
part of organ-specific
autoimmune diseases.
On the other hand, you
know, mixed connective
tissue disease, scleroderma,
rheumatoid arthritis,
Juergens syndrome are
considered and of course
lupus are very non
-organ specific diseases.
So one of the things that's
to really pay attention
to as a physician is
that autoimmune diseases
are referred to or they
seem to be considered as
hunting impacts. The
reason that's considered
is because they seem,
whenever somebody has an
autoimmune disease, they
seem to have other ones.
For example, a lot of
data suggests that like
30% with patients, sorry,
with lupus also have
Jorgen syndrome. And they
sometimes even have a
second, third, or even
fourth autoimmune disease.
It just seems like once
you have that rupture
intolerance, there's
a huge spillover into
multiple multiple tissues
and especially with
systemic immune diseases
they seem to have
a lot of overlap a
little bit less with the
organ specific so those
seem to be more they stay
in within that one disease
but the systemic ones
seem to be problematic and
they start encompassing
other diseases so something
to look out for when
you are treating a patient
with such a disease
There are three stages
that are identified
for autoimmune diseases.
The first one being
priming, and that's
basically, it could
happen from like the
environment or genetics.
So, for example, if you're
exposed to radiation, or
if you have a certain gene,
like a specific one, actually
a specific gene that can
predispose you to autoimmune
diseases. Now, those
will not by themselves
trigger an autoimmune disease,
but they may end up signaling
it, at least starting
it. And then what happens
is you end up getting another
stage, which is called
the subclinical. In that
stage, stuff is happening in
the body at the cellular
level and probably at the
tissue level. But at this
point, there's no symptoms
happening and the patient
may not recognize what's
going on until it hits the
clinical phase. and that's
when you start seeing actual
symptoms of the disease.
Exploring this more, again,
priming basically
talks about, again,
a risk factor, like
we talked about
some of the MHC
genes, like HLA-B27,
and then you have an
environmental exposure, like
sometimes it can be an
infection, sometimes it can
be radiation. So now we've
seen a lot of association,
for example, between epstein
-barr virus infections
and multiple sclerosis so
somehow the interaction
between a pathogen and
the susceptibility and
genetic risk of a patient
may result in triggering
autoimmune disease
here you can see the
different like associations
between different
autoimmune diseases
and different genes and
with the stage two we
talked about so again
there's a subclinical
stage, you don't see a
lot of symptoms or no
symptoms, it's almost
asymptomatic, but of
course the organs are being
targeted, but there's
not sufficient damage.
This results in what's
called epitope spread. As
more damage happens, more
epitopes become exposed,
more damage at a point
where it becomes such a way
where you start seeing
symptomatic disease and then
end up in the stage three,
which is the clinical.
okay and this is here
talks about just an example
of like how symptoms
of rheumatoid arthritis
start showing so as you
can see here like your
stage one nothing's going
on and the subclinical
stage is really hardly
anything and then sometimes
diagnosis can come here
because you start seeing
minimal symptoms showing
up and maybe detecting
of different antibodies
in the body and the key
factors and then
eventually if disease left
unchecked you could end up
with chronic destruction.
Again this is just a review
questions for you, one
of them is to fill in the
blanks and the other one is
a multiple choice for you
to practice some of the
information we talked
about. Again all the answers
for those should be in the
material that's given to
you so try to solve them
that way by exploring them.
So we just described
autoimmunity and typically
different stages of autoimmune
disease and how does that
relate to tolerance. Now
we're going to talk about
possible mechanisms of how
autoimmune diseases arise.
What are some of the things
that could happen and why
do we get them? Why do
suddenly we get tolerance
rupture? So these are some other
examples and we'll discuss.
So some of them we use.
Sometimes the presence of
what's called super
antigens may do that, having
defective receptors, the
phenomena of molecular mimicry,
a defective process
of apoptosis,
epitope spreading,
we'll talk about that a
little bit, I think we
mentioned that prior,
we talked about systemic
lopus erythematosus,
cryptic epitope exposure,
the hapten effect,
inappropriate MHC
expression and upregulation,
defective T
regulatory response,
hormonal imbalances,
cytokine dysregulation,
and sometimes pre
-existing organ defects.
And so looking at
superantigens, so the thing
about superantigens is
they're by definition don't
bind to where typically
the antigen should be.
So this is an example of
your, let's say, dendritic
cell, androgen presenting
cell, and here you
have your helper cell and
here is the MHC class 2
T cell receptor binding
and your should be your
like the co-receptors
which is your costometer
signal b7 ct28 but so
the antigen usually is in
the center between the T
cell receptor and the MHC
class 2 now what
superantigens do is they come
and actually bind on the
outside of the receptor
so they not bind none
specifically and trigger a
massive action or activation
of T helper cells.
Some recorded research
shows that sometimes this
can activate up to 5%
of all lymphocytes in
the body, which is by
the way massive. At any
given time, not more than
0.01% of our T cells are
activated. So this would
result in some serious
cytokine release,
inflammatory response, and
this could also trigger
an autoimmune disease.
And another example of how
good autoimmunity could occur
is when you have autoreactive
B cells with defective
receptors. And so those do
not respond to any inhibitory
signals and they are
unable to maintain self
-tolerance, so they go ahead
and end up attacking our body.
So again, typically
they should be going to
NRG, as you can see from
the slide, or during
central tolerance and
they're being deleted,
but sometimes they undergo
neither or they slip
through the cracks and
end up causing that.
Another example is what's
called molecular mimicry and
this actually happened with
several type of pathogens
and what it is is the pathogens
sometimes that infects
our body has antigens that
look very similar to our
own body antigen and as a
result once the antibody
response is triggered it
cannot differentiate between
the foreign substance and
the actual self antigen ends
up attacking both. A good
example of a few of those
incidences is streptococcus
pyogenes bacteria so which
basically when people get
strep throat in some instances
almost a percentage of
patients will get these
antibodies cross-reacting
with antibodies of the heart
valves. This can result
in what's called rheumatic
fever, which is why treatment
of strep throat with
antibiotics promptly is
important. This also happened with
campylovector jejuni.
So campylovector
jejuni can also
trigger through its
lipopolysaccharide with
LOS, what's called Guillain
-Bayer syndrome. And so
there's an association between
a C-chitin-I infection
and Guillain-Bayer, and
there's also an association
between Yersinia intercolytica
and the thyroid stimulating
hormone receptor.
And so, again, in some
individuals, not everyone,
infection in these bacteria
can result in attack of these
particular antigen in the body
and triggering an autoimmune
disease. They for now
not refer to as molecular
mimicry because it mimics
the molecules. The molecules
on the bacteria
or pathogen look
similar to some of
our own receptors.
Epoptosis as a receptor,
sorry, apoptosis as
a process can also be
defective. Many different
things can happen wrong,
unfortunately, with
apoptosis. You can have
too much apoptosis,
so an accelerated apoptosis,
and this results in the
spillover of cell antigens,
which can trigger an immune
response. You can have
defective presentation of an
apoptotic cell to a lymphocyte,
which then triggers an
autoimmune response, or you
can have failure to clear
dying cells by macrophages,
which then results in a
prolonged exposure of the
internal, like antigens,
like sometimes DNA, RNA,
proteins that are found in the
nucleus and so on, to the
immune system, which then
can recognize them and
not developing an anatomy
response. This is, you know,
this is the case of lupus.
Another phenomenon is epitope
spreading, And this occurs
when you basically start
attacking the first epitope,
whatever the first antigen
that comes up, and then
start attacking other epitopes
after that because they
are similar or sometimes
the attack of the first
epitope results in so much
tissue damage that you end up
exposing more epitopes,
which now become a target of
the urine system. Here there's
a figure kind of showing
how that could happen and
potentially, you know, the
cytokine response, excess
tissue destruction, you may
end up with a lot of debris,
which then can be presented
to the helper cells,
resulting in activation of
other cells, which then can
trigger an immune disease.
Cryptic epitope exposure
is another mechanism. And
again, just don't forget the
word epitope. Epitope is that
specific part of the antigen
that the antibody response
so crypto epitope exposure
from the word cryptic
it's been hidden so basically
we've had an androgen
somehow in the body that was
never been shown to the immune
response and then suddenly
it becomes so there's a
lot of sites that for example
the immune response have
never seen for example a lot
of areas in the cornea the
eye has never ever had any
exposure to immune system
***** for example in males
have never been exposed to
the immune system so if you
ever expose those, it can
happen. You can trigger a
lot of your disease. We see
those example of type 1
diabetes. There's apparently
some particular proteins in
the beta cells of the ****
of Langerhans that have
never been exposed, and they
do end up getting exposed,
and then when that happens,
immune system recognizes
them, triggers the fighting.
We also see that sometimes
with some viral infections
like Coxsackie virus that
end up after you know
like having respiratory
disease with Coxsackie end up
with post-viral myocarditis
and I'm sure you've
heard of several cases of
myocarditis as a result of
COVID and so it's not uncommon
for respiratory viruses
even influenza and so forth,
end up with a myocarditis
type of sequelae after
exposure to the virus.
So this is not an
uncommon thing, I guess,
among viral diseases.
So you can add to this
example also SARS-CoV-2.
Another mechanism referred
to as the hapten effect.
A hapten, by definition,
is a small molecule that
by itself does not
trigger an immune response
but if it combines with
another substance together
then they can trigger that
and so we see that for
example with thrombocytopenia
triggered as a result
of like heparin so you
use heparin heparin binds
the platelets and the
combination of heparin and
the platelets triggers the
body to actually attack
the platelets and the
result of their destruction
and hence thrombocytopenia
when you stop the aspirin,
basically, or sorry, or
you stop the heparin,
then it reverses and no
longer happens. And this has
also been documented with,
actually, with aspirin
and type 1 diabetes, or
somehow the aspirin also
interacts and acts like a
heptin, binds to beta cells,
islas of Langerhans,
and then triggers the re
-response. Here's, again,
an explanation of this.
And here an example of
like thrombocytopenia,
how the heparin
binding to the platelet
triggers an antibody
response against them and
resulting in destruction
of these platelets'
heptid effect.
Another mechanism is the
inappropriate MHC expression,
also upright relation.
So as you can see here,
this is pretty much everything
happening incorrectly here.
So
So this is normal here.
MSC class 2, representing
foreign antigen, you
get a foreign antigen,
you express MSC class 2,
activate a naïve T cell
with the co-stimulatory
signal there, get a normal
response. Right here is
a kind of an abnormal
response where instead of
presenting a foreign
substance, you're actually
presenting an endogenous
peptide on MSC class 2.
now this happens during
early on in life when we're
looking at central tolerance
and t-cell selection but
this should not happen later
in life so this process
should be restricted to early
in life when this happens
later this could trigger these
t-cells to recognize this
endogenous self-antigen
as a self and then trigger
the immune response this
is pretty much whether is a
defective T-regulatory response.
An effective T-regulatory
response results in immune
suppression and usually
preventing of autoimmune
disease, but a defective one,
as you would conclude,
would be the opposite. The T
-regulatory cells are not doing
their function correctly,
then they're not
suppressing the immune
system as it should.
This will result
in a immune system
that's spilling over,
damaging a lot more
tissues than it should be.
Hormonal imbalances can also
cause or trigger autoimmune
disease. An example of
that is a low level of
circulating corticosteroids,
mainly cortisol we're talking
about here. So, you know,
under normal conditions,
physical stress, mental
stress, oxidative stress,
nutrition, all kinds of different
stress act on the brain,
which then through the
hypothalamic pituitary
anterior pituitary axis results
in the adrenal gland making
cortisol which then blocks
inflammation, perfect.
But chronic, again normal
acute versus chronic type
of stress where something
is continuous all the
time and not managed
properly etc and ends up in
basically too much or
just a constant release of
cortisol which then results
in the receptors becoming
more resistant because
of negative feedback.
This is then prevents or
inhibits the typical action
of cholesterol which allows
it to block inflammation
and so it becomes a poor
blocker of inflammation
and our inflammation
just keeps increasing
increasing and this could
result in damaged tissues,
expelling, exposing
of epitopes and other
mechanisms which can
trigger non-immune disease.
One clear one is the
cytokines do not properly
work or cytokine
dysregulation. This could
result from either too much
cytokine being produced
or there's a defective
cytokine receptor.
Again, there's some
cytokines that are very
important in either
activating or in suppressing
immune response so if
neither of them work very
well you can end up with
an aberrant immune response
or you can end up activating
typical self-reactive
T cells which are allergic
so for example too
much IL-2 can cause that
while for example a defective
transforming growth
factor beta receptor would
result in less suppression
so any again the
importance of cytokines in
activating the immune response
and suppressing the
immune response becomes
clearly obvious when you
have a type of dysregulation.
How could that lead to
an autoimmune disease?
There can also be pre
-existing defects in the target
organ. For example, in some
cases, let's say there's
too much uptake of iodine
by like the thyroid this
could be or this is one
example or related to like
transcription factor
controlling the rate of insulin
production in type 1
diabetes and so these type of
aberrant conditions by for
example these particular
organs can result in triggering
an autoimmune disease.
And again just quick
review questions to help
you integrate some of
that information or check
your knowledge so forth
about about this lecture.
The next few slides
are pretty much summary
and then which is important
here to recap that
the tolerance is a very
complex immunological
process that occurs in
both primary and secondary
of course central
tolerance occurs in primary
while peripheral tolerance
occurs afterwards
and basically mostly in
secondary organs when
tolerance rupture that's
called autoimmunity
and autoimmunity
involves at least
three different
stages we talked about
priming subclinical and then
clinical and there's two
different cat two categories
of clinical categories
of immunity we have the organ
specific or the systemic
and we talked about
different mechanisms by how
which other immunity can
be triggered such as heptin
effect such as defective T
regulatory cells and this
is obviously an ongoing
field that we keep exploring.
This is just the references
used and as always
I appreciate you listening
to those lectures
and again if you have
any feedback about
the lecture I also
appreciate your comments make
sure you go to this
link and put those in.
Good luck studying!